six deaths are now connected to a
growing public health crisis tied to
vaping the newest deaths newest death is
in Kansas where health officials say a
patient who used e-cigarettes recently
died of lung disease the exact cause of
that illness is under investigation the
CDC says it's looking at more than 450
cases of vaping related illness across
the country three of those cases are in
Houston where Janet shamlian is at the
city's Health Department Janet what's
happening there Anthony good morning
well the city's health director is
calling these illnesses an outbreak and
the CDC is reporting at least 33 states
and the US Virgin Islands have cases of
this severe lung illness directly tied
to vaping Hawaii and Idaho announced
their first cases on Tuesday now some of
these involve vaping both nicotine and
marijuana and this morning the fear is
the number of cases will rise this is a
new outbreak which is occurring across
the nation
Houston's health director talked about
the expanding epidemic tied to vaping
its exact cause still unknown but in
three confirmed cases there's one
specific connection what are the
commonalities in these cases so the
common area we're seeing these cases
unfortunately is that all of them are
young people this is the age when people
start making their life choices and this
is a bad choice the CDC reports more
than 20% of high school students use or
have used vaping products 17 year-old
Whitney Livingston was hospitalized two
weeks ago in Dallas she and her mother
blame her two-year vaping habit for her
severe lung injury the ventilator was
the best thing because she could not
breathe on her own the deadly
respiratory disease that has now claimed
six lives across the u.s. is impacting
people of all ages the Kansas Department
of Health says a patient over 50 who did
have pre-existing conditions died as a
direct result of vaping others becoming
sick have been young and in good health
Idaho and Hawaii reported their first
illnesses Tuesday and the American Lung
Association is out with a new warning do
not use e-cigarettes I think the one
Association is giving very sensible
advice Stephan Glenn was professor of
medicine at the University of California
San Francisco says it's time for the
Food and Drug Administration to ask so
far
they've they've expressed a lot of
concern but they haven't yet issued a
single regulations about e-cigarettes at
this time no specific product or
ingredient can be definitively linked to
these illnesses and that's a big problem
for investigators looking at this
doctors here say of the three people
who've gotten sick they are recovering
but they're not certain whether they
will ever fully recover
Tony frightening Janet thank you very
much